all right here we go pft live the usual
friday draft now on a thursday because
i i i am fairly confident that tomorrow
morning at 8 4 a.m eastern i will be
asleep and i think chris will be
too so we're doing the show me something
draft now
chris you have a trivia question for me
to determine the first pick in the draft
all right here we go
entering the season the browns and the
bucks had the two longest active playoff
droughts in the nfl if the browns clinch
this weekend
what team will now have the longest
active
playoff drought
[Music]
wow i'm i'm thinking of teams and it's
like no they were there and i think of
another team that's like no they were
there
holy crap uh the pressure's on sometimes
the obvious answers are the right ones
sometimes the obvious ones are the right
ones the jaguars no the jaguars were
just in three years ago go ahead blow
the horn
but you were called it was saying who is
it you know the jets the jets you were
right there that's what i was trying to
say
jets jaguars right there at the bottom
yeah jets yeah it's been 10 years
crazy my god bring back i've joked in
the past that they should just fire
everybody and bring back rex ryan
maybe they should i don't know maybe
i don't know maybe they should i don't
know what they do i could say
it would be an ultimate i mean you're a
yankees fan wouldn't it be a great new
york thing
bring back billy martin bring back rex
ryan well
martin won world series and things were
good it didn't you know rex ryan it was
good for two years and that was that
okay i mean rex ryan got him as far as
anybody has in 50 years
i know i it's it's that ship has sailed
okay that's that's gone i hope it's rex
ryan bring
back rex all right you got the first
pick okay
well i think i am going to go
to tua that's where i'm going to got to
show me something this week it's my
first part
first time taking part in the show me
something draft but
i look at tua and of course that's the
miami dolphins in general
it's a big game you got to get in the
playoffs listen i don't know what the
hell the bills are going to do but
either way i just you need to be playing
high level football tua who got benched
last week fur fitzpatrick
you know again yes and this big moment
and okay if the run game and bootlegs
aren't there
you know can tua can tua do it on
offense with his left arm
and in the pocket making plays that way
that's still a question
about tua as we go forward here so for
me this is another good opportunity for
him to show me something and show
everybody that
you know he is a legit face of the
franchise
quarterback as we go into maybe the
playoffs or the 2021 offseason
he responded really well in the game
after he was benched against the broncos
for ryan fitzpatrick so this is his
chance what
you know even though he says all the
right things and does all the right
things this gets back to our
rogers conversation at some level it had
to bug him
to be removed from the game and to be
deprived of the opportunity to work the
kind of magic
that fitzpatrick did so you have an
opportunity to channel that frustration
the following game with the season on
the line the postseason birth
hanging in the balance i agree with you
tuatanga vailoa is one of the top
choices this week
for me tyler murray similar argument not
that he was benched
but here they are with their playoff
hopes that seemed
like a no-brainer for most of the season
they looked like one of the best teams
in the division if not potentially in
the conference at times they never were
in that conversation it was always
saints or bucks or packers
or seahawks maybe rams for a little a
little while
but they always were kind of on that
fringe and now lately they've fallen
apart
and th this is kyla murray with an
injured leg a shoulder that still may be
a little bit of a problem
getting it done against a rams team that
beat him earlier this year
if kyle murray truly is ready to be the
next great thing in the nfl
you got to get to the playoffs in your
second season and you have to win
a game in week 17 where it's win and
in and it's not going to be easy but
that's what's gonna make it all the more
memorable if it happens and that's why
the pressure i think chris is on him to
deliver i agree i mean i i think the
the aura or the shine of kyla murray has
definitely
dulled over the last five or six weeks
to where
you know again five or six weeks ago i
had to do right
my top ten quarterbacks in football and
i made him number four
i mean if you made me readjust that
right now he would not be there
i know that you know definitely not it's
been a lot of
average and even below average play and
come on let's be serious
i mean that interception he threw in the
game the other day he got me
kind of got a free pass in the media
that was a horrible interception and a
big moment of the game
no pressure on him just threw the ball
up off his back foot
and threw it seven yards short you know
so there's been a little too much of
that that's a little concerning with him
to where you just go man
what's going on there in in arizona um
my i got to go to the the browns baker
specifically okay if we're just going to
make it about one guy it's of course the
whole browns organization
but i'll put it on the quarterback baker
mayfield everything like that
you got the pittsburgh steelers who are
not going to be at full strength they're
coming into town it's the cleveland
browns you got a chance to go to the
playoffs do something here
you know against a team who's not going
to be playing all their starters
you know put them away you want to be a
playoff team these are the type of games
you got to come out and make sure your
team
is hitting on all cylinders your
energy's good
you're focused ready to go and you got a
chance to
you know solidify the fact that you're
the number one pick in the draft then
look you pick me number one
and here we are a few years later and
we're going to the playoffs
and we were crap before this uh this is
a big show me something weekend for
baker mayfield in the cleveland browns
yeah if they can't beat mason rudolph
they have no business being in the
playoffs and if they missed the playoffs
after that percentage that first time we
had kornacki percentages and they were
in the mid 90s right
i thought man the only thing worse than
being as bad as they've been the past
few years would be missing the playoffs
when you're this
close to it and if they can't beat mason
rudolph
they don't belong in the postseason next
one for me
a team that we just presumed to make it
to the playoffs and they may end up
blowing it
phillip rivers should be able to beat
the jaguars but we thought that way back
in week one and this very well
could be the final game of his career he
said
earlier this week that the thought has
crossed his mind they could win this
game and still not get in
if all the other teams at 10 and 5 win
they're not getting in the colts are on
the outside looking in
and it could be that philip rivers walks
away into retirement with a victory
there's already some buzz i saw a report
from frontofficesports.com that
the networks are lining up for the
possibility to hire phillip rivers
as kind of a tony romo figure covering
games next year if he does indeed retire
so this could be it
and uh this is your chance and you can't
lose to the jaguars you can't let the
jaguars two wins of the year
be week one against the colts and week
17 against the colts with the playoff
berth
hanging on it and again this may be the
last time we see philip rivers win or
lose so show us something philip
it may be your last chance to ever do so
yeah that's right and you know listen
in full transparency and transparency
i'm i'm i'm
i'm rooting for them i really am i mean
it's a hard year to go like who would
you want to not make the playoffs i mean
all these
teams here in the afc there's like
redeeming qualities of all of them to
make you want to
like root for them you know just you
know cleveland baltimore miami
indianapolis
it's all a good story and they're all
easy to root for that way
um and i you know i don't know i guess
in my heart of hearts there is a part of
me that wants to see phillip rivers get
in
i just feel bad because i don't know who
you cancel out of that and what's crazy
still too
really is hey they can win this weekend
deshawn watson pulls off some magic they
can win the division and be hosting a
playoff game too
that's what's crazy you know there
really is and you know the tennessee
titans with that defense
desean watson the way he's playing
that's a little scary down there that's
that's
very scary uh i mean watson you brought
it up earlier
he almost single-handedly beat them the
first time around
you know he he kept them in the game and
made so many plays
in that one so uh that's a good pick by
you and i'm rooting for philip rivers
all right i'm gonna go to uh the windy
city here
you know it's it's it's been a whirlwind
of a year in the windy city let me just
tell you it's been a whirlwind it's been
everywhere okay but
this is where i want to go to khalil
mack and akeem hicks
that's where it's the bears defense
that's gonna have to be
big time for them to win this football
game i actually have enough confidence
in their offense right now to go
they're gonna hold their own they'll be
okay but bears defense has been
you know leaking oil lately they've been
leaking it and if they think they're not
gonna win the game they're gonna let
aaron rodgers score 35
38 40 points no way that's not going to
happen
they got to step up and be big time and
the packers offense so balanced right
now but i think hicks
khalil mack it starts with them they got
to make a play or two
to give their team a little advantage
during this game if they want any chance
to win it
the leaking oil line reminds me of
another tv analyst one of your good
friends you know who says leaking oil
all the time or at least used to when i
used to actually watch more of it we
don't know who it is
no no no you've got your guys steve
young mr laissez-faire he'd say leaking
oil he'd also say moxie a lot
leaking oil and moxie were two of his
big ones yeah i don't even know
i just i don't watch a whole lot of the
pre-game shows anymore i focus on the
games
i get enough hearing about football
doing this show
and pftpm and football night in america
so i don't need to take in any more all
right my final pick
i'm gonna go jaylen hertz for all the
reasons we previously discussed this is
an opportunity this is a bowl game
this is the eagles in prime time the
last game of the season
it's a win-win game for washington it
means nothing for the eagles
this is the the chance for jalen hurts
to cement that he's the guy
for 2021 and there's reason to feel good
about jalen hurts for 2021 not just like
oh well
i guess we'll take him over carson wentz
because carson wentz is so bad right now
this is an opportunity to inject some
excitement into that eagles team going
into the offseason if hertz has a big
game so
i think he can do it and it would be
something to see the team that has
nothing to play for chris knock off
the washington football team in there
winning an opportunity to win the
division
it really would be i mean it's an
intriguing matchup nonetheless
you know washington that defense they've
had a few issues with running
quarterbacks this year
everything there washington's offense
not real special
to where you go man the eagles defense
could be okay versus that group
you know it's a scary game it really is
i don't know which way this goes that's
where it's like you know
the nfc east as horrible as it is it is
intriguing this weekend because
i think any three any of those three
teams could be hosting the buccaneers
you know next weekend and of course you
know i'm rooting for big blue and the
giants to pull it off so sorry
washington i'm
i'd like to see you lose sorry
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports